hello my name is Jolie earland and I'm a
research associate at the University of
Manchester in the translational radio
biology group and today I'm going to
talk to you about the importance of
understanding the hypoxic status of the
tumor microenvironment
in relation to cancer patient treatment
response and about the hypoxia
Associated gene expression signatures
that we as a group have derived
developed and validated to change the
face of precision cancer medicine
directing cancer treatments and
improving cancer patient outcomes and to
help achieve this we have also spun out
a company from the University of
Manchester called Mantra Diagnostics
Limited
so the challenge there is an unmet need
because currently there is no easy
accurate reproducible way to clinically
measure tumor hypoxia
now biomarker development is fraught
with failure at the moment
98 of biomarker development programs
failed to progress to clinical
application meaning that all of these
studies that have been invested in are
patient is never seen the benefit of
and developing gene expression studies
at the moment is attractive and this is
due to the availability of publicly
available data sets which allow the
validating of signatures and signatures
have entered the clinical arena for
molecular stratification such as the
pro-signia signature the oncotype DX and
the mama print
I'm working Manchester within our group
we have developed tumor type specific
signatures for assessing hypoxia and our
focus and our great strength as a group
is our ability to validate validate
validate our signatures on independently
collected clinical cohorts and our Focus
has always been on the route to clinical
application for patient benefit
so why Target hypoxia patients with the
most hypoxic tumors do worse and their
cancer is more likely to spread and this
data is from a landmark paper from the
Danish head and neck cancer group
demonstrating how patients with hypoxic
tumors have worse outcomes hypoxic
tumors are like more likely to spread
following surgery and hypoxia leads to
resistance to radiotherapy chemotherapy
surgery
and we believe immunotherapeutic agents
will be affected by hypoxia and we
understand and believe that
understanding tumors hypoxic status is a
powerful tool in choosing a patient
population where these modern targeted
therapies are more likely to work
improving patient outcomes
there are loads of Publications
highlighting the importance of
understanding hypoxia in relation to
treatment response and as long ago as
the 1950s experiments showed that a
three-fold higher exposure to radiation
was required to kill hypoxic as opposed
to normoxic cells it's not possible
clinically to increase the dose of
radiation to compensate for solid tumor
hypoxia due to normal tissue toxicity
there's therefore a great unmet need to
deliver strategies to identify patients
who are at risk and deliver targeted
treatments to them improving patient
outcomes
and despite all of this evidence and the
high quality data demonstrating the
adverse effects of hypoxic tumor
microenvironment and the benefits of
targeted hypoxia modifying therapies on
treatment response it is still not
routinely delivered clinically
so our solution we have developed
rna-based gene expression signatures
associated with hypoxia generated from
the original
diagnostic biopsy
and they are able to stratify patients
receiving various treatments for solid
tumors and predict those patients who
would benefit from targeted treatment
so what tumor specific signatures have
we developed
um what do we have
so we have four signatures
um all four of them are between 20 and
30 genes they are taken from the
original diagnostic biopsy as I
mentioned
we have validated them across multiple
platforms all automated it's very easy
to score
um the prostate
um bladder head and neck and sarcoma
signatures are all prognostic and the
head and neck and bladder have also
shown to be predictive of benefit from
hypoxia modifying therapies for example
with the bladder signature we showed
that bladder cancer patients who
identified as having hypoxic tumors who
are then given hypoxia modifying
therapies have a 30 increase in overall
survival
all of our signatures are validated in
multiple cohorts which you can see on
this slide and we also have two
signatures in the development pipeline
for lung adenocarcinoma and cervix
so we use the tree pre-treatment
diagnostic biopsy and we can generate a
score within 48 Hours the multiplex
nature means that it is a gives a
robustness to the signature reducing
intra tumor heterogeneity and our assays
have been technically validated and
shown to be sensitive and reproducible
the signature Discovery strategy I'll
just give a quick overview because I'm
not a bioinformatician but known hypoxia
seed genes were selected and then a
co-expression network was developed this
was done using the large publicly
available data sets and independently
collected cohorts
they were derived and validated on
multiple independently collected
clinical cohorts and the tcga
resource really helped us to develop
these strategies
so our oldest and most developed
signature is the 26 Gene had a neck
signature
um it was briefly um given overview of
its development it was
um and originally developed to be a 99
signature and then this was refined down
to the top 26 genes whose expression was
most closely connected with the known
hypoxia seed genes this was then
technically validated and delivered
originally on the tacman low density
array qpcr platform the signature
was shown to be predictive of benefit
from hypoxia modifying Therapies in a
phase 3 clinical study
and the head and neck signature has just
finished its final qualification in the
Nimrod phase 3 study which was head and
neck cancer patients
um in a placebo-controlled trial who
received
radiotherapy or radiotherapy and a
hypoxia modifying agent
we have also developed a health economic
model to deliver the cost benefit of
using our tests or our signatures as a
biomarker to identify radiotherapy
patients who would benefit from hypoxia
modified modification
we have the 24 Gene sarcoma signature
that demonstrated patients with high
hypoxia scores measured during with
signature have a poor prognosis and this
was demonstrated in two large
independent cohorts
we have a 28 Gene prostate signature
that was been validated in 11
independent cohorts prognostic ability
has been demonstrated in both high and
low risk prostate cancer patients and
patients with hypoxic tumors do worse
and finally we have a 24 Gene bladder
signature it has a similar derivation
strategy to the head and neck signature
and in a study where body cancer
patients were given radiotherapy and
hypoxia modifying therapies instead of
radiotherapy alone
these patients had a 13 increase in
overall survival
however the patients who were identified
as having hypoxic tumors using our
signature
they they showed a 30 increase in
overall survival really demonstrating
that it was the hypoxic patients who saw
the most benefit from targeted hypoxia
modification
so the current patient Journey patients
present and are given their cancer
diagnosis from the original biopsy and
there's a one-size-fits-all approach
given a low response rate
the beauty of patient stratification
particularly using hypoxia is that the
test can be measured from the original
diagnostic biopsy so there's no extra
intervention for the patient it's very
straightforward
and the hypoxia score if it's if they
score high demonstrating they have low
oxygen in the solid tumor at the start
of the Care pathway they can be they can
be
um
directed towards treatments that are
more appropriate to their tumor
microenvironment and patients who are
demonstrated to have a good oxygen
delivery they they can go towards
standard of care and be confident that
that's appropriate for them and this
will give a higher response rate
so we are a radio biology group and all
of our research is focused on bringing
benefit to radio bio radiotherapy
patients however we understand that
cancer
is treated by targeting the 10 main
Hallmarks of cancer and we want to
extend the utility of our signatures
beyond the area of radiotherapy now all
of these Hallmarks are influenced by
hypoxia
so we decided to focus our attention on
the immune activating agents or the
checkpoint Inhibitors and the parp
inhibitors these drugs are radically
changing cancer treatment
however the response rate is really
still quite low and being able to
identify patients early doors that will
respond to these treatments would bring
much better outcomes for cancer patients
so our hypothesis is that patients with
tumors who have a high level of hypoxia
will have a poor response to
immunotherapeutic agents and patients
with tumors with high levels of hypoxia
we'll have a good response to the pulp
inhibitors
so can hypoxia can hypoxia signatures
stratify patients for checkpoint
Inhibitors well hypoxia is
immunosuppressive and expression of pd1
pdl1 and ctla4 is directly regulated by
hypoxia
and if hypoxic tumors are resistant to
these checkpoint inhibitors our
signatures could be used to let patients
with well-oxygenated tumors and increase
the probability of response
um so so to demonstrate this we we need
to do some proof of principle studies to
extend the utility of our hypoxia
biomarkers
so to address this extent in the utility
see if we can offer benefit in other
therapeutic areas we carried out a small
proof of principle study looking at
recurrent metastatic patients who had
been treated with nervolumab a
checkpoint inhibitor and the study was
carried out in collaboration with our
clinical colleagues at the Christie
Hospital in Manchester in the UK
the hypoxia scores were generated from
the original diagnostic blocks as I
mentioned and the study showed that
recurrent patients those patients whose
disease returned after their primary
treatment they had more hypoxic tumors
at the at the start of the Care pathway
and on the right this is a very small
cohort there is a blend a trend for
patients with low hypoxia to live longer
and remain on
immunotherapeutic treatment longer our
tests demonstrating the extension of its
utility albeit in a very small cohort to
identify patients who respond to these
agents
we are looking to extend this cohort
with our clinical colleagues and
hopefully we'll be able to present that
in the future
we also have a collaboration with
AstraZeneca
with the aim to extend the utility we
ran our signatures through AstraZeneca
clinical cohorts and we clearly
demonstrated an ability to stratify
patients based on their hypoxic status
we showed that the test was prognostic
the patients who scored high for the
hypoxia did worse and died sooner this
is demonstrated by the captain Myers on
the left I also demonstrated an ability
to predict benefit from the i o agent
the volume up
for patients who had low hypoxia scores
um it's not significant again due to the
small sample size but there's a clear
discrimination in these two patient
populations and we're working with
AstraZeneca to acquire samples from
another one of their clinical studies
that failed to meet its primary
endpoints and we think that using our
test we will be able to
um
identify patients based on their hypoxic
status who would respond better and we
could see if we could improve
discrimination by identifying these
patient responders and improving the
trial endpoints
now for us to achieve our goals to
deliver into the NHS which has always
been our Focus as a research group and
to work with large Pharma to extend the
utility we needed to migrate our tests
from the qpcr platform over onto a
platform that fitted in with clinical
workflow
and to achieve this we've transitioned
from
qpcr as I mentioned onto the targeted
rna-based Next Generation sequencing
panel and this fits in seamlessly with
what the genomics laboratory helps in
the UK use as their workflow and the
genomic laboratory hopes are the
organization that deliver the genomic
tests for cancer patients in to the NHS
in the UK
this would also allow us to deliver for
biomarker-led clinical trials which we
have in the pipeline and we could offer
also offer it as a researchy Sony tool
to retrospectively evaluate
immuncology agents to CFR test could
identify patient responders
we want to clinically deliver our tests
for radiotherapy patients that has
always been our Focus
and as mentioned we fitted in with the
clinical workflows
by migrating onto an NGS panel and
demonstrating its concordance with our
original platform and we've worked with
or are working with the Northwest
genomics Laboratory Hub to deliver this
for patient benefit
and the release of the nimrad outcome
data the final phase three qualification
that I mentioned before will be input
into a healthy economic framework which
we've had commissioned which will give a
cost benefit hopefully for using the
test to identify patients who would have
benefited from hypoxia modification
prior to the radiotherapy and this if
this shows a cost benefit
then we can Lobby nice for our tests to
be used as a biomarker prior to
radiotherapy treatment
so in summary the advantages of patient
stratification based on hypoxia it is
a non-invasive test taken from the
original diagnostic biopsy it gives
information across the whole of the
patient population
and patients who are identified as being
hypoxic at the very start of the Care
pathway can be directed to appropriate
treatments and those patients that have
good oxygen delivery are not typoxic
tumors can be confident that the
treatment that they're getting is the
best for them
and the take home message from me today
is that tumor hypoxia is important and
hypoxia can and should be measured in
all studies
thank you very much for listening and my
contact details are there if you'd like
any more information
thank you